más Romero salas tiene las noticias de
la salud en directo a América Buenos
días para usted Buenos días Ángela Pues
bien Vamos a comenzar con sus noticias
en Perú el gobierno decretó la alerta
sanitaria por polio y por sarampión
tenemos que preocuparnos pues
Definitivamente sí no es que hayan
crecido muchísimo los casos sino que el
riesgo de que existan estos brotes es
mayor especialmente Además desde que
finales de marzo Perú encontró un caso
de polio su primer caso de polio desde
1991 en el caso del sarampión en lo que
va de 2023 se han notificado seis casos
y el año pasado fueron 129 aquí tenemos
las regiones que están en alerta vemos
que incluye la capital lima y la región
alrededor de la capital también amazonas
que fue donde se encontró Este primer
caso de un menor de edad con parálisis
en las piernas por los cuales pues se
detectó que sufría de polio y también
vemos pues muchas de las de las regiones
fronterizas que de hecho están sacudidas
algunas por
de conflictividad social en el sur todo
el problema de migración que están
enfrontando enfrentando ahora es decir
que bueno llega esta alerta en un
momento un poco convulso y un poco
complejo en el en el país es importante
recordar que tanto la polio como el
sarampión son enfermedades víricas
transmitidas por virus y las Américas
toda la región de las Américas fue
declarada libre de polio en
1994 y el sarampión fue declarada libre
de sarampión en 2016 por lo tanto sobre
todo esta alerta Viene un poco a
ponernos a recordarnos que si no siguen
estos esfuerzos de lucha contra las
enfermedades pues existe el riesgo de
que vuelvan a aparecer cuando ya se
habían logrado erradicar es que estas
enfermedades escuchaban mucho cuando
ustedes y yo éramos niñas Pero en este
momento poco
y se muestra un poco esta tendencia que
va cambiando gracias a las tasas de
vacunación o contra estas enfermedades
pero que en Perú son más bajas de lo
recomendado Sí en Perú y de hecho en
muchísimos países ahora de la región
latinoamericano un poco por ese olvido
de Cómo eran las cosas antes no tanto la
polio como el sarampión son enfermedades
perfectamente prevenibles con la vacuna
con vacunas que llevan además en uso
durante décadas y que acarrean el
esfuerzo de campañas de vacunación
masivas en esta región latinoamericana
que consiguieron estas erradicaciones no
vemos aquí en las cifras las tasas de
vacunación contra el apoyo es del
81,8% una cifra del 2022 de todos los
niños que habían recibido las tres
vacunas las tres dosis del esquema de
vacunación contra la polio y en el caso
del sarampión las cifras de 2021 es un
66% esto cuando en lo que se recomienda
por la OMS y las autoridades sanitarias
es llegar a una tasa de vacunación del
95% algo que entonces previene que
aparezcan rebrotes de estas enfermedades
pero es que además es importante también
decir que en el caso de la polio por
ejemplo se superaba en Perú este 95%
sólo en 2018 hace 5 años bastante
recientemente y un ejemplo
definitivamente de estas caídas de las
tasas de vacunación en Perú pero también
en toda la región y además una región
las Américas que había sido una de las
más vacunadas del mundo que más rápido
se había deshecho de enfermedades por
ejemplo como decíamos como la de la
polio y que más se había esforzado en
estas campañas de vacunación masiva
sabemos que la pandemia de covid fue
difícil como que retrasó todos estos
esfuerzos también el discurso
antivacunas que ha surgido durante esta
pandemia de covid ha calado fuerte en la
sociedad Y por supuesto eso que decías
lo que mencionábamos antes no este
olvido vamos muy rápido olvidamos muy
rápido Cómo eran las cosas antes de que
existieran estas herramientas que ahora
tenemos disponibles para intentar
contrarrestar esto el gobierno peruano
también ha anunciado una campaña de
vacunación para dos millones y medio de
niños de 5 menores de 5 años que pues
que intenten inmunizarse en los próximos
meses Pues es que aquí Lo importante es
eso que reaccionen rápidamente vamos a
hacer un cambio de tema madre y hablar
pues de salud de las mujeres poco
mucho más bien Yo diría poco se habla de
la salud hormonal de las mujeres y esto
tiene consecuencias a muy largo plazo
hay un nuevo estudio que está
relacionando el ciclo menstrual con las
enfermedades cardiovasculares si vamos
con las conclusiones principales de este
estudio que lo ha hecho el hospital de
perdón en un hospital en China y que es
muy interesante porque recoge datos de
más de 58.000 mujeres de más de 58.000
personas entonces los datos que arroja
estadísticos son Realmente fuertes en
este caso las principales conclusiones
son que los ciclos menstruales
irregulares están asociados con más
incidentes cardiovasculares en los
ciclos demasiado cortos digamos aumenta
el riesgo en un 29% y en los ciclos
demasiado largos en un 11% sucede
también que aumenta el riesgo de lo que
se llama fibrilación auricular que es
cuando hay una arritmia en el corazón y
eso sostenida digamos y eso puede
provocar coágulos en la sangre lo que se
considera además importante decirlo es
que realmente sea de 21 días o menos y
ciclos largos de 35 días o más es decir
variaciones bien significativas de la
media de 28 días que suele tener un
ciclo menstrual también bueno decir que
no observaron ninguna relación ni con
infartos ni con ictus ningún accidente
cerebrovascular sino que son más este
tipo de problemas que estamos diciendo
no Claro Habría que ver que son los
ciclos largos y cortos dependiendo de la
región del mundo donde estemos las
mujeres porque no nos afecta el ambiente
Pero además mar porque todo con la
menstruación es normal el dolor es
normal el digamos el escándalo de la
menstruación es normal Así que sí hace
falta más revisión hace falta muchísimo
más de investigación tanto en la
menstruación como en las enfermedades
cardiovasculares en mujeres Pues es que
justamente Este es un paso que nos
permite comprender un poco más las
enfermedades del corazón en las mujeres
Sí porque es una enfermedad que suele
tener una mirada muy masculina no
sabemos que afecta mucho a los hombres y
eso ha hecho que a veces se pasen por
alto algunos detalles importantes los
autores del estudio de hecho aquí
recordaban que las enfermedades
cardiovasculares son la primera causa de
mortalidad para las mujeres en todo el
mundo y que ya se han observado algunas
cosas que tienen que ver con el ciclo
menstrual y estas enfermedades por
ejemplo se han propuesto varios factores
de riesgo como el síndrome de ovarios
poliquísticos también la menopausia
temprana se sabe que está asociado con
enfermedades cardiovasculares entonces
Proponen más investigaciones como esta
precisamente para encontrar estos nuevos
factores de riesgo que se puedan tener
en cuenta es importante decir que aquí
el estudio lo que explica de nuevo es
una relación entre dos cosas No
necesariamente una causalidad sino que
puede ser por ejemplo sucede sabemos que
los ciclos irregulares tienen que ver
también con causas hormonales o con
inflamaciones crónicas que luego pueden
afectar también en enfermedades
cardiovasculares es decir puede haber un
factor común que afecte a las dos cosas
más que que una sea la que causa a la
otra o también puede ser otra de las
hipótesis que se maneja es que realmente
por ejemplo en los ciclos menstruales
largos menos exposición a los estrógenos
que es la hormona femenina digamos y eso
está esta hormona tiene un efecto
vasodilatador entonces ahí puede también
tener algo que ver con las enfermedades
cardiovasculares con el flujo de la
sangre no pero sea como sea es
importante entender que si hay esta
asociación puede servir tanto para
ayudar a diagnosticar o cómo para
monitorear es decir si sabes que tienes
algunos de los factores de riesgo estar
más pendiente entonces de revisar las
enfermedades cardiovasculares o la salud
del corazón Así que toda información por
supuesto es buena Yo lo que diría mar es
que si se invirtiera más por parte de
los sistemas de salud en la salud
hormonal de las mujeres Seguramente se
ahorrarían muchísimo dinero atendiendo
otras enfermedades comprenderíamos
también muchísimas más cosas que ahora
mismo Todavía están sin luz y seríamos
más felices gracias a ustedes Muchas
gracias